welcome to my show i've been so excited
for this episode
it's with young gravy young gravy is an
american rapper
singer songwriter producer and
entrepreneur and i
really love his music it's so catchy he
just released a new remix of his song
oops with lil wayne
last week he's a bright guy and this
conversation was really fun
we talked about working in the music
industry record labels
some of the background of what that
industry is like how he got more well
known
and more kind of cool to hear what that
industry is like from a man on the
inside
please remember to subscribe if you
enjoy this kind of content every sunday
and wednesday
this episode is made possible by hover a
domain name
vendor something that makes hover
special is it has a ton of options for
different endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from
when building your brand online no
matter what you want to build there's a
domain
name waiting for it you can end your
website and blog or dot
diet or whatever instead of a com if you
so choose
i use hover for that reason sometimes
adding a
dot something to your website can be a
better idea than a full on new dot com
although they also sell dot coms of
course i just bought
mp.show actually it's not linked to
anything yet so
don't search it but it will be check
them out at hover.com
mp and get a 10 discount with that
referral link
also linked below on all new purchases
make a name for yourself
at hover hover.com mp link below
and here's young gravy enjoy the episode
[Music]
young gravy welcome to my podcast kayla
thank you for having me i'm happy to be
here
well hopefully this is going to be fun
so where did where did a young gravy
come from does everyone call you young
gravy now is matthew gone
no um people do i would say
it's it's i don't think people really
say younger i almost never hear great
young gravy the full it's gravy if it's
someone who doesn't know me that well
uh young gravy when you're in trouble
young yeah the full name when i'm in
trouble
uh no all my um everyone who knows me
will probably still call me matt
um young gravy
actually came from um so i used to work
at a summer camp when i was i think that
would have been
i went to the summer camp from age like
10 until
until 17 that i worked there from age 17
till say maybe 1920 um
as a counselor uh and i said teach kids
how to sail it was it was
very wholesome um and
the gravy name basically
um a lot of times after the kids would
all fall asleep and my friends would go
out and you know just
uh find a spot in the woods and
you know smoke a blood or whatever it is
that you know
have have uh this is we're talking
northwoods minnesota so this is how we
how we did
get it up there and we would go up and
freestyle
rap over just some some random uh
beets and everything and i kind of had a
i kind of had like sort of a moniker you
know
i would go by mr butter that was kind of
my go-to but then
there was one moment one day where i was
freeze down something and i said
something about gravy i don't remember
the exact bar but um
i said something like come through
smooth call me on gravy
and then from that moment on it was just
like everyone was like that's that there
it is
like that that's that and then so then
within like the freestyle
circle which is like a solid 10 people
that i would see
uh maybe in the summer and then i kind
of died down i forgot
like when i started going to college i
stopped working there but
um i always kept that that name and
uh in mind i i thought the idea of being
a rapper would be awesome but i never
thought it i was like there's no way
i'm from minnesota people don't do
people don't do that here
um and then and then yeah i mean i
i i paid a lot of attention to these uh
soundcloud artists
soundcloud artists and more low-key
artists
that are making that come up just
through the internet and
basically after working
well i'm going beyond just a question
but yeah eventually i
i was like you know what i want to do
this and young gravy is
the perfect perfect title for what i
want to rap about so
that's where that came from okay okay
let's back up a little in case anybody
doesn't know who you are
um who are you and what is it that you
do
all right i am a
uh i think i am a kid from minnesota
i'd class myself classify myself as a
soundcloud
rapper which isn't as much of a thing
anymore because soundcloud kind of fell
off
but luckily i i hit it at the right time
um grew up in rochester minnesota
which is uh basically the next biggest
town after the twin cities
and um i went to
school at university of wisconsin i know
you're canadian right
yeah i think i'm actually further south
than you which is really sad
yeah for an american that's very rare i
went to uni
then i'll say i went to uni at the
university of wisconsin
madison which is where i started making
music
um start a bunch of different majors and
everything and
i ended up in like the startup vc space
and that was where i really was like yo
this is cool but like i could do the
same thing for free on the internet
okay what is hold on hold on what's vc
venture capital
oh my god i can't believe i had to ask
what that was
okay and you said you can just do the
same thing i'm sure there'll be a lot of
moments that are the
reverse of that during this podcast um
[Music]
so then yeah i went to university
university of wisconsin for three and a
half years
and uh the timing was pretty great and
right as i was in my last semester
i was basically getting flown out to new
york every week for
record deal meetings um because i would
get home from class
every day during my like sophomore and
junior years and just
make music and go ham on soundcloud and
social media and all that
um and then
one of the coolest things for me was
like okay so that's a marketing major
you know and it's it's a
heavily heavily female major
you know and going up to the teacher and
saying oh yo i got this um letter from
universal music group and i need to go
to new york so i can't make it to class
tomorrow you know that was that was like
for me at that time coolest thing ever
but i
uh signed center record deal and all
that and
started my tour my first tour like
within a month of graduating
school so basically i graduated wild
december 2017 and i've been kind of on
the road
since then until coveted
yeah kobe kind of put a kibosh on
everything
tour wise so what was that like that's
that's canadian we say kabash
no you don't no one says kabosh maybe
that's a me thing
i don't know i'm not good with that type
of thing but i could be wrong
maybe the comments will tell us kabash
or kybosh
we'll find out kai bosh okay so what was
it like then
you went from university that must have
been completely absurd being recognized
for music
and is soundcloud a place i don't know
much about soundcloud is that a place
where you can kind of upload whatever
you want
anything anything you want um
and i think this term soundcloud rapper
kind of just
developed from like people who were just
like
it would be anybody who just wanted to
just like upload their own [ __ ]
and um a lot of these artists were just
like
being very experimental and throwing up
random different types of
music um you think of other
soundcloud rappers that became really
big xxx
uh tentacion ski master slump god some
people might recognize these artists
um or other artists that kind of came
out of that realm and really blew up
little peep
uh russian piece a lot of artists um
sort of it was it was a great um
way to kind of grow uh music
because because it was uh social media
mixed with a music platform and
unfortunately spotify and apple music
kind of took over since then so
there's not really that that way to grow
anymore
still people still use it but uh it was
cool because i
sort of would make friends on there make
a community and you'd support each other
and kind of had a really good algorithm
for
for growing your um whatever type of art
it was
do most people find music now on spotify
has that just taken over
it seems like spotify is really the main
the main thing yeah
and obviously tick tock is just crazy
huge now
i totally ignored tick-tock for a while
i'm still ignoring tick-tock
terrible mistake i'm making but i hated
it i thought it was so cringy
and i remember i i uh
was really the one good thing i thought
trump was going to do was going to be
ban
banning tick tock i was the one thing in
my mind i was like let's do this
and then that didn't happen um
and uh but i finally embraced it full
though right
i finally embraced it and i think it's i
think it's gotten better like like i'll
go on there now because because tick
tock hit me up and we have sort of a
partnership going on
where i post things um through my
account but i actually go on there and
look at stuff and
and they my what i think yourself about
them is somebody
on their team created one of the best
algorithms that i've ever seen in social
media i pay a lot of attention to like
statistics and all that and their
algorithm is great because i know that
my mom uses it and she will start
sending me things and it's like they are
tailoring things to what my mom
likes they look at how long you like to
pay attention to how long you look at a
video they pay attention to like all
these different things
and tailor everything on like your
little feed to
what you're interested in and it's like
it's crazy like my mom will be on it and
it'll be all this wholesome mom
stuff but it'll also be like inspiring
things and i look at mine and it's like
it's like way more like hip-hop focused
and like um we i don't know just like
crazy
funny things but it's it's it's i gotta
give it to them they have somebody on
their team who
who nailed the the algorithm yeah so
they figured out how to make it
interesting for everybody
and the one downside in my mind is is
that it seems like
tick tock kind of has a like the
influence of tick tock on music
and popularity of music is just a little
bit too crazy
like it's it's it's pretty huge like
i've noticed that
um dropping out the album that i dropped
before tiktok was big versus the album
that i dropped advertise talk was big
it's like the songs that get used on
tick tock are noticeably the big ones on
the project where before that it was
like
the sort of objective quality of the
song i
i can't say objective with music it's
like the the song itself
like that i thought would be the biggest
is the biggest where now it's like oh
someone else made it trending so now
it's the biggest yeah
is there a way is there a way to get
your song to trend or is that just
purely by chance i think it's scary
it's pretty heavily by chance but i know
that people
people try really hard to like there's
definitely people who put a bunch of
money into that
and pay people to to post their things
uh like post videos with their music on
it and
um i've made i've made friends that are
that are actually pretty that are
actually cool that you stick talk and
and they'll support the support
music that i put out and i've i'll note
like i've noticed
it it definitely helps
no matter what it is like even like a
one big video going up
will assist a little bit but but i
another like i mean that's another thing
that i do respect about it is that
you can't just put money into it and
make a song blow up it's like
the people it's got to be something
original you know
okay okay switching directions slightly
i want to know a little bit about behind
behind the music industry scenes because
what i've heard from
probably just reading on social media or
in the news is that
if you're an artist and you sign to a
label
they take all your money and they can
take away some of your freedoms
is that dependent on the artist is that
how it works like i i know that i know a
couple of independent musicians and
they're always saying you know the
reason they didn't sign is because
i don't know exactly why but what's your
what's your experience been with
with that yeah i i could talk about this
for a while
um but also my labels and someone on the
label
you can be nice about it yeah um
i am a lot different than most artists
in
the i mean with the fact that the
majority of my fan base is very like
hardcore cult fan base like
more or less it's like my fans either
people who who hear my music either are
like all the
[ __ ] that like i'm out of here or
they'll hear a couple songs and like get
really into it and become like a
hardcore fan
like like i've noticed fans that like
like it's the type of fans where they'll
come to like
i'll go on tour and see the same fan in
three separate cities at like meet and
greets like it's like those type of fans
so basically it's very organic
and and that's something that labels
can't create right it's
labels are great at taking an artist who
has
a mainstream sound you know someone who
has a sound
um they'll take someone who's really
good looking
and has a nice voice and then pair them
up with someone who's a songwriter which
i know
currently i mean not here but in l.a i
live with all songwriters
so i get that part of it too they'll
pair them up with someone who can write
a good song
and then tell this good-looking singer
to sing a song and then that person
becomes
you know that's that is how it works
that yeah
i mean it over like yeah more or less
that's how it works
and and they that is how a lot of these
artists
um you know you know
i can't even throw around names because
a lot i mean any artist that's pop and
there's i'm sure that they've done their
own thing there's there's definitely
people say industry plants that are out
there but like there's also
huge artists that are write their own
stuff
you know and say um ed sheeran et cetera
but um for me
it really depends on the type of artist
because my music is very
sort of i won't say niche but very like
sort of off the beaten path unique
stuff like um
a sound that no one else really has and
that is something that
um works very well as an independent
artist
right so i i signed
because i was my music was taken off so
fast
and the people that i met initially who
um i my first
managers that i worked with when i was
kind of pressured to like find managers
that's a whole other story um the first
few managers i started working with i
mean one of them's alright but one of
them is like so
slimy that he ended up having recently
had a whole he he slimed like some bunch
of people out of their
success and stole all this [ __ ] like
from i've stole
is that from taking cuts that are too
big or hooking you up with the wrong
people
it'll be like yeah i mean basically i
ended up like just being told by
whoever i met in the music industry all
this is who you should work with
basically there's this dude
who recently had a whole rolling stone
article written about him and and
the fact that people can like take
advantage of artists in crazy ways
um my lawyer wouldn't let me do an
interview or anything because of the
threat of
the defamation defamation i ever say
yeah yeah yeah yeah threat of lawsuits
from the kid's dad
uh so i couldn't do anything but
basically like
there is um
i don't know there there's a heavy
everyone
it's a slimy industry right and everyone
wants to get their own bag somehow
and um i was sort of convinced to sign
like people kind of made me feel like i
had to do it oh if you don't do it now
like your career is going to like
yeah it's a huge opportunity mm-hmm and
i did it
um and i don't hate it i mean i mean i
would say in the first two years
and and i mean just overall a lot of the
growth
is because of me not because of a label
because but it's not necessarily their
fault because it's it's it's a very it's
it's this
organic fan base or whatever um
but oh i've i've spent a lot of time
bitching people out on the phone
i had a lot of people i've had to deal
with but but the team has gotten much
better i
actually am finally happy with my label
after like two years
but um the music that i released before
i signed right i said two years ago and
music that i released before i signed
i think i get close to as much money not
i would say like it makes about his half
as much money
as i make like the check basically the
checks that come straight to me
from releasing independently i make
about half as much money as i do from
music that i've dropped through the
label
and the amount of views play streams
everything that have come out of the
label music is
basically it's it's yeah like you said
the independent i wish everything was
independent
because my fans are so hardcore that
that like one independent song that i
have that is huge
is making me five times as much as an
equal song that's on the label just
because they
have all those rules like you were
saying but i've gotten better at kind of
understanding it and
negotiating with them and figuring
things out
it's really confusing there's too many
roles and too much going on
yeah and at least you're how old are you
now 24.
yeah so you at least you're not like 16.
yeah and this is happening to you
because you have no bargaining power and
no no idea
what was going on and i'm a decent way
through the
sort of the deal that i signed um i put
out two albums with them and i think i
have
to do uh two more
uh which i'm gonna bang out quick so
um is there a time frame for this kind
of thing
yeah there's always little rules but
it's like it's basically if you put the
music
out and get it out like basically it's
like each period
each period you have to do i think it's
for me it's like 14 songs and if you get
those out
it's like they decide whether they're
ready to move on to the next one
and then it's called options so they
pick whether you get another one
basically so it's like if an artist
puts out their music and it doesn't do
well they have the power the label has
the power
to just drop them you know it's like
yeah it's
clearly something that was developed by
these music industry people
way back and it's just stuck around and
it's not
super fair to artists and i wish people
could just be
educated on the whole industry before
they
um start with anybody yeah
well it's interesting things have
changed so dramatically with social
media
that people ha people who have a
following have so much power as their
own brand
it's the same thing for self-publishing
books or going to a publishing house
it's like you used to need the
publishing house to get your book out
and now
you can do it yourself and it's vaguely
the same with music
given youtube and spotify even
like i think billy eilish i don't know
much about the music industry to be
honest like anything i think the only
thing i've learned was from
that queen's movie that movie on queen
and
that was probably not accurate but i'm
pretty sure billy eilish got famous off
of a
song she put out on spotify with her
brother just for a school project
yeah i've i um have a good friend who's
worked very closely with her and i think
yeah it's it's she's another artist who
really had like the organic
growth and then but also her sound is
very
very um friendly for radio and all that
so it's like her music once she was
signed when she did sign it worked
really well
but but you know that like she's i'd
call her
genius in the music uh realm i think
that she could have done on her own but
for a lot of people the label is the
right move you know but
um booking tours if you have an agent
too but is that separate
an agent in the label completely
separate there are there are 360 deals
there are a lot of artists
i'm i'm blessed to have had a really
good lawyer who got me a good deal
where where my music is one thing with
the label but everything else is
separate
and and i'm like really into doing my
own merch and doing my own tour
oh you got merch out of the deal
yeah oh everything's separate yeah yeah
oh good for you
i'm a big business kid you know and i'm
a marketing kid and i'm i love like
branding and designing things so like
my merch is a whole whole separate thing
my
touring is a whole separate thing like i
do have a really good deal so
i'm blessed overall because because i
have
basically the only thing they control is
just the
the streams or whatever the new music
but blaster is smart
that like that that's good so then for
for two
lawyers
disagreeable very good at taking not
taking no for an answer and kind of like
i'm really good at bitching people out
too that's that's a skill of mine
um so kind of like
asking every damn question and like
figuring out exactly what's right
so so yeah that i guess it was it was a
good part uh
my decision to separate everything and i
was like
part of my deal is literally no creative
control from the label i get all
creative control all this you know
um because i really just like the
branding
all that is that's my um
that's my bread and butter and um
yeah so the merch and touring is
completely separate
um some artists i didn't realize so then
do some artists
have that wrapped into their deal
like with music industry merch for sure
i know that with touring yes some
artists do
um basically like the the term 360 deal
um basically means they like kind of
give you more money up front but kind of
take control of all that stuff and i
know that a lot of artists get sucked
into that
there's this new thing called a
production deal where like basically
you're
the people who are setting up the deal
and the managers kind of take like a big
huge cut of it and i
i don't like i don't know it's a to me i
i i think it's kind of
it's 10 it's becoming more mainstream
to have this production deal thing where
it's like the people who are
bringing the artist in are getting like
just as much as the artist is and it's a
to me that doesn't make any sense
because they're the ones who really
create the art um
but in my case and i think in in at
least in
a lot of the older like like if
a lot of this more slimy [ __ ] seems to
have come up in the last couple
years so i think overall touring
and merch is separate in a lot of cases
so um
ultra i wonder if these i wonder if
these people are getting nervous too
given
given social media and independent
artists popping up
like there's a lot of there's going to
be a lot of adaptation that's needed in
some of these industries like
publishing houses the music industry
even even managers and agents just
because of how much power the individual
has because of social media
i'd be nervous oh yeah and then and they
try to
they do try to you know jump on social
media and like
join the trends the labels do and it's
almost like
you kind of got to help them figure it
out you know because they're just like
oh you know like let's
do this but then i mean there's always
companies that can hire for that but
um social media totally gives artists
power to do this thing on their own you
know
there's there's artists that get pretty
pretty huge before they sign a deal and
and it makes a huge difference i mean i
mean
relatively i was i was a lot bigger than
the average artist
who signs and and my deal that i got
from a label compared to like a lot of
people that i've
like worked with is was was vastly
different just because
um at that level they're like oh this is
you know they have somebody back there
doing math like oh this is worth this
you know so yeah yeah and i suppose
there's less of a risk to them
if you already have a following they're
like this guy's going he's already made
it
so we can sign him and give him a little
bit more because we're not risking it on
somebody who doesn't have much of an
audience yet
so so overall i got lucky on that front
and then
also um one of my best friends his
name's baby no money
bbn oh dollar sign he's from vancouver
canadian
he um i met him very early in music like
when we were both like
just starting on soundcloud and we've
done a ton of music together
basically i i got lucky and i kind of
blew up before he did and i was kind of
bringing him along with me right and
featuring him on music
featuring him on songs and giving him
attention um
and then he really blossomed and like
got all this
his own growth and er but i signed
because of my
like first huge blow up and then
i've been keeping him from signing ever
since i've been like dude don't do it
don't do it
he's independent he's still independent
yeah
okay and he blew up i do i do i actually
had to google how to say his
i i've i've like seen bbno double uh
money sign like i've seen that or a
dollar sign um but i had to google how
to say that before this podcast so it
didn't sound like a [ __ ] although now
i'm telling everybody anyway
but baby no money yeah i think i've
found
i think i actually came across you
because i was listening to
a song he did with la la la la yeah
which everybody's heard and i was like
obsessed with that song and then he used
to always
open for me on tour and he would play
that song
as like unreleased he'd play it as like
a teaser
on my tours and and everyone would love
it and i was like this is going to be
the one
you know because he would always kind of
have doubts about things
like oh it's never gonna happen i was
like this this is the one
um and when him and y2k is the other
artist on it who's a good friend of mine
um and he's really taken off since then
too but
um ever since that dropped they did sell
that they sold that song to a label so
basically that's another thing that
is possible it's the same ones one song
you know
um and what's the point of selling one
song to a label are they supposed to
disseminate it for you or it's basically
is like if
if it's a very like like a pop song like
that one that has potential to really
blow up
um they can um
you know like with the label they're a
lot better at pushing things to radio
that's another thing i guess i wouldn't
really focus on is that okay um
my music isn't super suitable for radio
it's other than this new song my new
song oops that
has been getting radio spins but but
they put that one on radio and like if
it's like a song like that that has
really big pop potential basically they
can blow it up so they sold that one
song
to radio and he got way bigger
and now every time he hits me up about
like yo should i sign i'm like
no don't don't you dare i'm like for
i'll pay you to not sign
and that doesn't does radio really like
what percentage of the audience still
listens to radio
is that really a really big deal still i
don't know is that just what
is that just what the people trying to
buy your song or telling you or is that
the actual statistic really no
no i think it's i think it's a big deal
it's a bigger deal than either of us i'm
sure would expect
but but um i always was like oh it
doesn't matter i mean people don't my
music doesn't get put on the radio
because i talk about the craziest
things in my music and basically don't
make pop music i make
very experimental rap music um
but finally i've had finally just as the
last couple weeks have a song was on the
radio
and uh that increased his popularity
people it has increased the popularity
um i mean a decent bit but but but i
almost think it's a whole separate thing
it's like radio doesn't necessarily have
to go towards streams but it's like
if it's big on the radio and it does
well it'll get bigger and bigger on
radio it's almost like a whole separate
thing people seem to be really excited
about that
i mean at least that's the label and
so that's um that's new for me
okay how did you switch in directions
again although i probably want to get
back to the business aspect because
that's
fascinating but um how do you
choose the ol i have a i have an oldies
playlist in my spotify that i've spent
like four years just choosing songs and
putting them in my oldies playlist and
i'm obsessed with it
and so you have the song mr clean and
it's
it samples miss sandman
which is a just a great song um how do
you
how do you choose what samples to use
and how
is there a certain amount of music that
you're allowed to use
legally like how do you get away with
taking these snippets of other people's
music which is genius
like i i know kanye west does it and i
absolutely love
that but how do you get away with doing
that so the sampling
situation is pretty confusing and has
has
taken me a whole lot of time throughout
my career like
learning how to deal with that and
figure figuring it out but
um i've definitely done been through a
couple lawsuits
um when i started doing music i
basically i knew that you can you can
sample music
um if you clear it but from the start
my thought process was i don't have a
lawyer i don't know how to clear this
[ __ ]
so i'm just going to put it out with
these samples
well-known samples i mean i had a song
one of my first songs that really blew
up was
sampling george michael uh
careless whisper baby come back
uh a player a lot of these songs that i
put out
and um my thought process was
you know what if it blows up it'll get
me attention
and if they find it and they want to sue
me yeah
they can't really assume me for more
than the money i made on the song so
it's like
in my mind it's like i don't need the
money it's just like like i want to put
the art out there you know
so i have had three songs now that
have been taken down because of those
samples
um but it took quite a while for people
to notice
um so my message to people who want to
sample music
is is if you're not scared if you're not
too afraid of it give it a try
um there's a rule there's a rule that
i've
followed for most of my life which is uh
let me see if i can get it right
it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission oh yeah straight
up people will say no but if you just do
it and then apologize profusely
afterwards
generally you can get away with that
that's how mystery worked
we had to give them a big percentage of
a song but it was already gold
and they're not like oh we the the the
cordettes
estate they're that they're they're not
going to say well we
they're making money on it you know we
can make money on this song it's getting
all these streams a day
that's for mystic for mr clean like you
said that was that situation where where
they found it
and we said oh i'm so sorry it's a good
excuse
for for me because my lawyer can be like
oh it's just he's a soundcloud rapper he
didn't know he put all this stuff out
before
um and then they get a percentage of it
but you still have the song published
yeah
so still out there but since i signed
that's good for people too in my opinion
that's good for people
like once they once they get the
percentage if everything's fair
then like most people don't listen to mr
sandman
or they don't know what it is it's a
very old song it's a really good song
but
i mean repopularizing this stuff and
reusing it totally i don't think there's
anything wrong with that
totally and um there are a lot of i mean
i've had a lot of songs that we we
pitched
to get cleared that got denied because
it's it's you know i mean
i i tend to sample things from between
the 60s and 80s
um and a lot of these artists are older
and don't approve of hip-hop and
i mean in particular my music is is more
obscene than the most
fair yeah so i've been denied a lot of
things
um and another route that i've taken is
just to keep the sound
is uh re
replaying isn't the right word because
replaying technically means
trying to copy a sample with enough
changes in the in the notes and whatnot
to make it legally different enough
right it's called replaying a sample but
we do
what's the real what's the term for what
i've done basically i'll
work with a few different um
sort of like a almost a composer where
we'll bring instrument
instrumentalists into a session
um and play some soul music or whatever
i'm feeling that day
and then we'll kind of recreate not even
recreate just create a new sound
based on like inspirations that i've
brought in that i'm like oh yo
i'll bring a bobby womack song and the
curtis mayfield song i'm like yo i
really want to find a sample like this
and we'll kind of direct it the session
into making
music making a sample that sounds like
that you know
so a lot of my last few projects through
releasing through the label have been
like
at least half of it if not more are
samples that are original creations
uh by me and and one or two or three of
these
um i would call a sample composer that i
work with
um and doing that um
it's really fun you know it's it feels
like you're doing more than just
hip hop you know it's it's like you're
starting from scratch
um i love sampling but i know that it's
unlikely in a lot of ways to clear it
and obviously the benefits are higher if
you're not giving a huge percentage to
the
person who created in the first place so
recreating
soul music or or doo-wop or whatever it
is
um i really enjoy doing that because
it's it feels like i'm doing more than
just making a rap song
and it you know a lot more freedom with
it
okay okay which is which is not a lot of
artists do that and
it's something that i wish more people
like knew was a possibility
yeah well that sounds a lot more
difficult than just sampling it is oh
yeah absolutely
more difficult so it's a good i think
the direct trajectory that i took was
do the sampling thing get get the
right connections after you grow a
little bit and then
also it takes a little bit more musical
talent i was i kind of started more
yeah business kid like loved
music and all this but i hadn't really
ever studied anything and then i
i made music because i was like oh this
is what i should do
like i don't know that was kind of my
outlook on things on the business side
and then i started really growing and i
was like yo art is my [ __ ]
and um over time i was like yo maybe i
should actually do some things that are
original
and uh obviously to me everything
lyrically and
the beat wise is original but once i
finally started being able to create you
know
create the actual samples and almost
take like
my favorite style of music which is soul
all this older stuff and try to create
my own versions of it was like i don't
know that's my favorite
favorite part of it at this point
okay i want to ask some questions about
music videos too the background there
so when you're you've got some music
videos out they're very entertaining i
like how they look
um i don't know how my audience is going
to feel about this like my favorite
artists are
i really like johnny cash i really like
tom waits and i really like kanye west
i'm just like just across the board um
uh i was a little bit obsessed with
mclemore earlier
when i was in university although i
think he was very popular then
sorry when did you go to where where'd
you go to university and um
i went i went to university in uh at
concordia and then at ryerson both in
canada
um and concordia is montreal
okay it's an art school in montreal it's
like the school
people go to if they don't get into
miguel
i've been in just about every all of the
big
cities in canada except for uh quebec
and um
you should go to montreal montreal is
the most fun city that was the
first city i've bet i went to in canada
when i was a high schooler we took a
we took a a road trip out there um
in the middle of winter i don't know why
we picked that oh that's fine that's the
best time to go to montreal this was
great dark
minnesota so it was a huge difference um
but i loved it there
yeah it was awesome uh vancouver's
probably my favorite
in canada but um i mean i've been to
edmonton calgary toronto all that
and where'd you grew up grew up in
edinburgh i grew up mainly in toronto
i was born in montreal grew up mainly in
toronto i really liked montreal
but i was in university so it's just
great for partying
um i did i mcgill kids when i was there
i i'm sorry that's okay you probably
yelled at concordian kids too god i got
a lot of hate from mcgill kids
but they're not making podcasts i
remember the cute little bird
thing they had that's that's about all i
remember the cute little bird mascot
i remember that they used to play
quidditch i went on a school tour when i
was in high school i went on a
university tour there
and they were playing quidditch and i
was like i don't know i don't know about
this yeah that's a canada thing that's a
y'all thing
that's a canada thing quidditch okay
that's a smart okay okay sorry
that's a that's a uh
that's just a a mcgill type thing that's
like
harvard harvard
boston college people who
you know i i wouldn't see
did we we might have had a who might
have had a um
a quidditch club at wisconsin i'm not
100 sure but i
i guess i associate quidditch with like
a brown
student i don't know what i associate
quidditch with but i went to montreal i
went to miguel and thought
i don't know if i can handle this
university although to be fair if it's
where all the ivy league if it's the
sport the ivy leaguers play then they're
probably making enough money to make
quidditch worthwhile
really yeah perhaps
okay music videos music videos that's
what i was that's what i was getting to
so when you if you're you're associated
with a label you have a manager
how much of your music video design is
yours and i suppose
you everything and so when you hire a
director
like do you see what's going on in the
set and you're like that's not quite
right that's not quite right or do you
have someone there doing that kind of
for you
i think 90 of artists don't get involved
with that but i'm like a
perfectionist sort of really into
i don't know i'm really into all that um
i like to control everything so i'm very
even before the video i'll talk with the
director of time
um kind of develop the concept myself
usually and then let them kind of like
like i don't know as much about
the actual filming process but like with
the whole like
setup of everything and sort of like
almost like a
musical screenplay i like to do that
whole that part of things
um but label-wise it's i mean they let
me do my thing and you get does this
come out of your budget
or do you get a budget from somebody to
produce a music video for a song
basically the way i describe it um
i mean it's it's a little bit different
depending on the deal
but the way i describe it is um
no matter what the no matter what the
money
is for if you're with a label
the um whatever money's getting
the getting spent by them the budget you
have to recoup it with your
music so basically it's your money yeah
okay okay so you're not getting paid
until you
pay off their money so
if you have the choice like you can
spend you know
x amount of money on a music video but
then you have to recoup it
before you make any money yeah yeah
so so if i think a song is really going
to do well and deserves a crazy video
like the one that i have dropping in an
hour um
that video i was like you know what i
and also i mean for me it's like the
money that the money doesn't matter
like that in in some cases like it's
like i i really just wanted this video
to have it
or this song to have a sick video so
that this one is
what song what song is coming out it's
from casanova
oops yes oh that's the one that's
dropping okay
yeah yeah um
that that was one of my favorite author
project i'm glad that it's getting some
attention lately
um who's this video trey who's
gonna find out who tracy is is she in
the video yeah
yeah we'll find out who tracy is um
and this whole video was basically
not direct when i don't know what a
director necessarily does on a video
i i didn't tell him i'll film at this
angle but everything
about the whole concept was was my my
idea so you can kind of
you know look at this video and see see
how i really
you know my type of art there's there's
there's a
there's an antagonist dressed in a bird
costume
um yeah it's it's pretty deep
it's it's it's exciting i think you'll
enjoy it
okay check it out i'll link it here when
i post this
amazing amazing uh do you have okay
we're gonna switch directions again
um i asked my instagram i always ask my
instagram if they have questions for
whoever i'm interviewing
um and the main question i got was just
advice
for people who want to get into the
music industry
i have gotten this question a lot and um
i'd say if you're passionate about it
um you got to really care i think if you
want to
be successful in music you got to really
care it takes a lot of time
i when i started making music i
was working at a vc
firm venture capital um i had this dope
job lined up for after school
and i knew that if people found out that
i was making this sort of explicit
music but under another name i probably
would have a lower chance
of succeeding in that field so
um basically i i kept my identity under
wraps i didn't show my face or anything
for
the first year and a half making music
right is that part of the reason you
used a different name
i mean i wouldn't rap as matt harry you
know i i
not as catchy why does everyone put
young why is the young part so popular
right now
for me it was kind of just i was i just
wanted to like i thought you know i did
young then gravy i was just like no it's
not going something i
just thought i thought i was like you
know what i'm just gonna play along with
all this [ __ ]
um but what was my point with that
um basically it's it's that that kind of
differentiated me was
i'm not showing my face for all my
posts and art and everything i'm taking
50s 50s ads you know
and and taking art from like a whole
different era like these pin-up girls
and stuff and that that was kind of my
aesthetic
and keeping all my identity a mystery
and creating a whole brand
and sort of story about this music so
it's not just music it's like it's like
a character you know
and and um i think that brings a lot
more interest in
and and sort of my point with that is is
being unique um
sort of creating something that's
different than what everyone's used to
hearing
um is what i think really helped me take
off you know so so one of my really good
friends
um was a little peep who
created this sound of like sort of um
uh emo wrap um
with guitar sampled guitar and
this darker um lyrical content
and he was one of the artists that i
watched really blow up first and it was
like to me it was like oh
like he's so different from anybody
else that that like that
i love it you know you know what i mean
it was like
i love this because i haven't heard it
before
so i i took that sort of
concept and i said you know what i'm
going to sample
sort of this thing things that i listen
to i'm going to sample these songs
people haven't heard in forever
or sounds that are just just unheard of
these days
these days and kind of turn them into a
trap
[Music]
put put trap drums on them and make make
it into a whole new
sound and because i want to bring these
sounds to these
uh younger generations and
um i'm gonna rap about what i want to
and and the sort of
just just the fact that it was so
different from everybody else i think is
what really made it stand out
and i would say if you
are starting a career in music and want
to pursue it just don't
don't feel like you need to copy what's
popular because my music was the
opposite of what was popular and i
got people's attention by creating
something that they could feel
you know special they're listening to
this and it's like well no one else is
listening to this
and i i dig this because of you know
xyz um so being unique
for me is by far the the biggest thing
and
you gotta really want it because there
there was at least a year
year and a half where i wasn't getting
any type of
numbers or any type of reaction it was
the slowest growth
and then finally something something
will happen because
the internet is aware of the internet
things will get in front of people and
if the right person hears it
then someone's going to use it in a
video someone's going to use it
in something and if people
if it's the right if if it's right and
and
people like it it'll it'll spread
so do you know um do you know pair of i
think it's they're pronounced pair of
stellar
they had okay they do they sample music
again from like the 40s
50s and turn it into kind of electro
whatever electro 40s 50s music would be
you have a
song yeah i will i will after um they
have a
you have a song the boys are back in
town which i also really like
uh and it has one part that reminds me
of music
it's not pair of stellar because they
sampled it from somebody way back in the
day too
but i'll send it to you i'll send you so
they have something
similar to like the it's not similar
it's just sampled music from
from way back when it's not it's not
yeah
that that's that's one of the older like
one of the oldest of things that i've
sort of sampled
um i love i love good one no it worked
because that one was what was the song
are you allowed to say
that that actually was um
that one wasn't a sample it was it was a
sample of a
sort of it was it was something we found
we found
on like fiverr right it was like we me
and y2k were in the studio
and we were like yo just googling like
your 40s
like we just basically found it and it
was royalty free and we said we're just
gonna use it it was it was
somebody at their house playing on a
trumpet you know so
i just loved kind of the juxtaposition
and any way that i can kind of
trip someone out like oh wow this and
this you know like
my last album had a track that i sampled
the always sunny
theme song and put some of the craziest
possible uh 808s on it
um that feeling to me is just the best
so so i was like you know what we're
gonna get this
insanely dirty beat and then every 30
seconds it's gonna turn into
sort of this jive track and everyone's
gonna and i'm just gonna
that's the hook and then we're gonna rap
and like crazy people again
so yeah yeah legendary stellar does it
does electro swing
that's that's the term for his music
swing it's
so good and it's kind of like what you
do is way more
like now even even his is kind of dated
it's more i don't know modern i guess
what you're doing but um
it has the electro swing elements that
that are pretty good
you're in minnesota right now
[Music]
and i take it you moved away from
minnesota
when you could no hate to minnesota but
i mean
there are some areas that are more
comfortable that perhaps are more
interesting
um i love minnesota um do you
how big is how big is rochester i don't
know anything about it
do you know what the mayo clinic is yeah
i do unfortunately i do
but i don't know rochester minnesota
very well
the uh mayo clinics based in rochester
where i grew up um my dad worked there
as a psychologist and my mom worked as a
psychiatrist
treating employees of the mayo clinic
who didn't want to
get treated by their own co-workers
right
yeah fair hometown is about 150 000
people
and the mayo clinic has about 50 000
employees
so it's wow pretty much
those numbers are probably give or take
twenty percent cause i don't know
but yeah it's it's it's a huge part but
rochester is kind of centered around
mayo clinic
yeah that is i live i mean i grew up
downtown so i live
i could walk to one of the mayo clinic
buildings in
in five minutes um
the cold is the one thing that drove me
out here i love the people here
i come back to visit my friends i grew
up with all the time because they're
some of the most down-to-earth people
um but i come back all the time i mean
since
since i graduated and started tour i'd
say each year for me
was sort of a third on tour
and then the rest of it was kind of
divided between minnesota
la and atlanta because i spent a lot of
time in atlanta it's
atlanta it's a hip-hop hub yeah okay
so i'd be there a lot do you like
atlanta friends i love it
i love it you like it better than l.a
everything has its own i can't even
pick the the being between the three
i mean i've been i'd spend time in miami
as well and and
nashville and other places but like
those three to me are
like a perfect mix because it'd be like
there's vibes about atlanta i like
in in the studio there's a lot less ego
than la there's a lot of um this
community vibe in atlanta and there's a
whole
like the southern culture and hip-hop
culture there so much stronger than in
la where in la it's like everywhere i
work it's like yeah it's hip-hop there's
also going to be some electronic people
there and all this stuff
atlanta we're talking pure hip-hop and
then i come to minnesota for a break
from music where i'm just
chilling with you know the day ones and
seeing my mom and all that
it was different everywhere but but it
was a good it was a real good blend
okay um speaking of so i did some
background research before i did the
podcast
uh and i saw a clip from theo vaughn's
interview
where you said you were going to smoke
dmt with your mom
yeah haven't it happened you haven't yet
it's hard to get it in minnesota you
know i've
i've i like that that's what you what
you chose
um the one thing out of the interview i
was like that sounds like that could be
a story
i'm i'm a big fan dmt i think is one of
the
i'd people are always like oh if you
want to try psychedelics you gotta try
shrooms or else
have you done dmt yeah oh a ton
um i was so i was on probation for a
while in montana
because of some dumb things that
happened to me in georgia when i was 18.
and um my landlord
was making dmt so he that was the one
thing i could do while i was getting
drug tested that wouldn't show up
and i had all these reasons good to know
yeah yeah so i had all these really dope
experiences
uh in the backyard and
what they call what's the ten thing
people build in their backyards
um not a tp but uh
someone will comment what it's called
they have one of those 10 things in
their backyard in montana
bozeman you go out there and do dmt
every once in a while and it's
it's a crazy experience if you're into
psychedelics i'd highly recommend it but
did you go into outer space yeah i had
the blast off
i'd have quite a few times and then and
then on tour at one point i bought a
bunch of it in seattle
um too much about too much in seattle
and and then it was just on the tour bus
forever
so i was um i don't know i was just
i lo i felt like just some sort of
really good like
it's obviously euphoric but like i would
always come out of it with some sort of
new outlook on
something so i was doing it almost every
day before my meet and greets
besides so much so my my room on the
tour bus smelled like
burnt plastic at all times and
um i was basically entering different
universe
every day within 20 minutes of
meeting 100 hardcore fans and it sounds
like it wouldn't be a good combo but it
really was
um so did it help
okay so i haven't done dnt i've done
shrooms and i've
i've found if i go through something not
just positive but something particularly
like
negative um and then i'm kind of ready
to face that if i do some sort of
psychedelic then it kind of helps me get
through that
do you think being brought into fame and
meeting all these people who know
who you are do you think dmt helped with
kind of integrating that
because that's got to be pretty wild
um yeah that don't
i guess it's so except two separate
things the
fame and all that stresses me out like
like i
especially if i'm in like my hometown
where everybody knows me or like in
minneapolis i
go shopping for groceries after 11 p.m
when i'm not gonna get run up on by
everyone in the store so that stresses
me out but i would
i would separate dmt completely for me
dmt it's like
i if i do something like dmt i haven't
done acid in a while but like trims
usually it helps me totally separate
from anything
personally i completely separate from
anything career related work related you
know
it's it's like a break for me um
and just brings in other i don't know
just completely separate thoughts gets
me thinking about other things i could
do
um i've had sort of like i've been
inspired like to try other things a few
times
um there's a dmt
trims whatever it is and um
i don't know for me it's a break it's a
break i feel like
like like you said if you have something
negative you kind of gotta face
um i've totally had i've had a bl i've
had a mix
where i've had like a bad mushroom trip
at one point where it was like oh
like overthinking something but also
yeah
but that was i think i think it depends
on your environment because i was in
like a it was like late this is when i
was like 16 and i had this
girlfriend that was way older than me
and all of her friends were like these
like to me like scary dudes that are
like 20 something that are like
drug druggies and i was like wrong place
wrong time and it
stressed me out but i've also had times
where like i had some sort of little
epiphany or like oh i need to try doing
this i need to take something
i need to really try something
and go hard at it i mean like i wouldn't
say it's because of psychedelics but i
definitely got inspired to really
try at artistic
like really go a lot harder on my my
artistic side of things
versus like my initially i was more of
like a science math kid
and i think psychedelics helped me like
really embrace that like i had some sort
of
artistic is that what you're saying
you know i'd i'd be happy i'd be happy
if people call me heavy
i love i love that term um i don't think
i've been called that much
but but i would take it gladly
okay so you said your parents are
both basically have doctorates right you
said psychiatrists and psychologists
so how did how did they feel about you
pursuing a more
creative endeavor so yeah so
um what was the what's the what's the
dad joke they'd always say
um oh yeah a bunch of psychos you know
oh because my mom's a
psychiatrist as a psychologist and oh
yeah psycho parents or whatever
um yeah i haven't heard about that that
i like that
that's maybe that's their joke maybe
it's original i figured it wasn't but
maybe it is
um they i grew up i grew up with much
older parents um my dad was married
before my mom so i have half siblings
that are in like their one of them is
like 50 now i think they're much older
um and and yeah so they both met at the
mayo clinic
and um at first when i started making
music
my my dad passed when i was 16. so he he
he i
hadn't never had a chance to witness the
the music
but um my mom hear that
thank you i i knew my mom wouldn't mind
it
but but i still like i said i had my
face
and whatnot from like my my boss for
a while but like i i don't know why i
was just like i don't want to be that
kid that's like you'll listen to my rap
music
you know there's always i don't know if
you experienced that but i remember in
high school
i don't think that's a bad idea though
because the type of thing you're doing
it's kind of explicit
right it's going to like you said it's
going to appeal to some people
really appeal to some people and a whole
bunch of other people are going to be
like no
like hard no um and i can see you trying
to
kind of test it out to see if what you
like is also what other people like for
a while before being like
this is the person behind it i thought
you were from your voice you've got such
an amazing voice
i thought you were a black man for a
very long time
i think you get that yeah so there was a
solid
um probably
the first year of me making music and
actually putting like at least an hour
or two a day into it
there was maybe two or three people that
knew
it was me and i'm telling like out of
all my good friends i wasn't even
telling anybody like
like wow at the time when i was finally
ready to tell people i sent my one of my
best friends a link
to one of my songs and i was like yo
check this dude out i just found it it's
fire and i was wanting to hear what he
would say
um how long did you keep that a secret
for did you tell anybody
uh i mean just the kids that i lived
with because i had to because they hear
me recording it
um this then this is when i was uh
second near the end of my sophomore year
at uh
madison and um
finally when i decided to sort of reveal
it and i was like
taking things seriously um it was from
mr clean
the psalmist apples mr sandman we shot
this video
because i met these kids at a party um
and
and not not even kidding these kids my
music wasn't really i mean it was
getting there but it wasn't that big
and there was kids that i was at a party
with that i met um
there's this group of three dudes that
i've worked with i worked with one of
them since he came on tour with me
but they're like one of them said yo are
you doing gravy they heard my voice
and they recognized oh yeah one of them
said are you young gravy
because then because i had hinted at the
fact that i was that i was in madison
wisconsin
and we just hit it off we were all drunk
like yo dude let's shoot a music video
it's me crazy let's link up tomorrow
next day we're all hung over we meet up
at like like noon
and sit on their balcony and like start
talking about ideas
and remember what i remember i i never
thought about shooting a video yet but
what i said was yo
i really want i need a horse i need a
jet ski
uh and i think we should go to a car
wash and and then
basically we shot this video which is to
to this day
probably still my most viewed video i
think we probably spent a total of like
70 bucks on the video because these
dudes had like
equipment they borrowed from the school
and
we pulled some favors to find horses and
jet skis and all that
but i spent 70 on gas and then i bought
dinner for the
video crew um i made this video
that ended up being great and that was
how i revealed my face was i
i put out a video for my song that was
the biggest at the time
um and it blew up and i think a big part
of the reason it blew up was because at
least
half the comments were like yo i thought
this dude was black and he's not
and that's apparently a lot of really
exciting for some people
so um well it's it's just like you've
got a really good voice
and for some reason it's for some reason
a lot of people who
have that like deep voice with a lot of
background to it just end up being black
so it was surprising to me i was like
it's this like is this blonde dude
what that's funny cool but funny
i had a thank you i had i had a weird
when i when i was thinking about rapping
no one had ever told me i had like a
a cool voice for a little voice nobody
ever and and
can you hear people around you you don't
hear your own voice though you know that
you you hear me i don't know i feel like
i sound like a man
no you don't and and that's what you
have everyone has their own
their own belief about it well i heard
my voice on you know you hear your voice
on a recording you're like what
the [ __ ] is that okay and and i was like
you know what i think my voice is a
little bit too white to be a rapper i
was like i think my voice is a little
bit too lame to be a rapper that was but
that was my first thought and then since
then i think that just
my voice being low has gotten like has
been a part of where of
helping me get to where i'm at now and
like i guess i was wrong but i think
everyone has
i mean everyone has their own like
skewed
uh view of themselves but like voices in
particular it's like everyone thinks
their voice sucks you know
and maybe not everybody
i think yeah i think maybe i don't think
you're alone i don't think you're alone
i think you have a great okay well
that's good
i i haven't asked very many people about
the quality of their voice um
yeah i have and that's right yeah yeah
no wonder uh okay and then before
like one thing i i do have to ask you're
you're six foot seven
yeah that six foot six and a half six
foot seven i don't know i'll i'll say
i'm six seven if someone they'll be like
no you're six
six and i'll say i'm six six to the next
person i was like no you're six eight i
i haven't been to the doctor in a while
i don't know somewhere around there
taller that is taller than most people
yeah
so yeah it's cool though i appreciate
what you do i like the music
i'm not going to basketball not going to
basketball that's what a lot of people
ask i'm not going to basketball
um yeah you didn't think you had more of
a shot there because music is kind of
like that's all
it seems like a far-off goal for most
people's like i want to be a famous
musician
okay there i yeah no i tried i tried
um i wanted to be a competitive like
trick skier basically i was doing that
for a while i used to compete at like
you know like rails and flips and all
that and then i got hurt isn't it harder
to flip the bigger you are
yeah oh yeah it's not meant for tall
people either but i but i was i was
determined and then i got hurt pretty
bad doing that
um went into college as a physics major
i was really interested in like
like astro stuff and then
that was not fun after a little bit stop
that how long was a little bit
i took physics in in the university too
and it was also not fun
how long did it take for it not to be
fun less than a month actually
uh yeah okay and then i
did psychology for a while that's my
favorite for sure
um but then they got a really good
business school
at wisconsin so i was like you know what
marketing
pretty close to psychology so i ended up
doing marketing and finance
and then i draw the finance major at the
end so i could graduate early for my
tour
but um i've always just been i mean to
me now it's just like the
psychology sociology that whole realm
was the most interesting to me
um and i think that really has helped a
lot with
with branding and deciding what to do
with music
you know like like i never have studied
anything music related
i never really had anyone musical in my
family or anything but it was just i
basically based all the music skills off
of
not skills i based all my music
inspiration off of music that i listened
to
and then i've i've just kind of learned
from
working with people more about music i
still couldn't tell you if something if
you played a note on a guitar i couldn't
tell you what the note is
but i can tell you what sounds good and
i can
you know i could tell you what what a a
good wrap flow sounds like
um so everyone has their own way of
doing things but i think i started with
more skills in the branding department
and then have slowly become more of a
musician which is
people underestimate marketing
completely underestimated oh you're a
marketer or
you know marketing is like i don't know
let's look down on a little bit and they
just completely
underestimate that when you when you
listen to music do you get goosebumps
from certain songs
the word for that that i can't remember
right now um
arousal i don't know there's this
there's a specific word
very specifically with music there's a
specific word for
it's a feeling of awe when you get goose
bumps
god damn it i'm going to have to look it
up that's really annoying look at that
um goosebumps on
off you have a good example uh i think
one of the after
so after learning a lot about music and
now like knowing
what takes a lot of talent
i think when i hear telephone line by
elo i get goosebumps every time
there is electric light orchestra is one
of the most
talented groups i've ever heard like
they the amount of different
instruments and all these things coming
into it and the chemistry and like
the art and oh but i get i'd say
listen to telephone line even if you're
not a musician and and think about it
and that that song is insane
some of these is a super [ __ ] um
oh my god super true you have to listen
to super [ __ ]
right now there they have an album
called breakfast in america
you've got to listen to super jam they
have a whole bunch of instruments in
there their recording is
so crisp and so clear that gives me
goosebumps every time
it's like i think it's equivalent to
queen it's really good
okay all right well i gotta tell you
some more music now so um and everybody
um listen to how you say crank kwangbin
kruangbin um they have a song called
friday morning
that one gives me goosebumps every time
it's like kind of like a mac demarco
chill vibe but it's just uh it's
beautiful
um and there's this there's this 70s
italian funk song called okay okay
by pinot and that
is that is the epitome of what i wish i
could create
in music it is like the funkiest it's
it i would call it it's the birth of rap
this dude is talking in this low voice
and
just spitting these lyrics at a high
pace and
i'll text you the specific links but but
for anyone listening
okay okay about by pinot dangeo
friday morning by cranberry i'll post
all these below so people can listen
beautiful we need some good music in
these depressing coved times
um what's your plan what's your plan for
after things open up like are there
talks of
touring again are certain places opening
up
i had a tour erection
pilot erection have you not heard of
that no you should use that word pilot
erection and it's literally when all the
hairs stand up on your body
and people get it when they look at
beautiful sunsets or they hear some song
um or if they hear something really
emotional i get it
all the time i like the name though oh
yeah i got notes here's super trina
final erection
um what was the question
oh oh touring oh so so i had a tour
planned with dylan francis
who's an idiom dj um that was gonna
happen in
march of 2020 yeah 2020
and that got postponed to
no october 2020 and then it got
postponed to february 2021
and then july 2021 and now it's
potentially planned for november 2021.
um so four or five
times postponed wow um
what's crazy is that a lot of people
still haven't like redeemed or
what's the word whatever they have they
haven't got a reason right yeah refined
their tickets
um and i also have an australian tour
and a european tour that'll probably end
up happening before that but
most people in the touring realm
agree that touring probably won't happen
again until
something like um late summer
late summer if not later of this year
i hope it happens at least then yeah i
mean there's there's states where you
can do it i've had i
i had a show offered um for like
pensacola florida
next week so there's places that are
doing it next week
next week so there are places that are
doing it but but that's not really
i felt like i didn't really stop at that
i might wait a little bit longer before
i
consider doing a show a bunch of people
yeah
so there's places that are doing it
there's people there's people that are
figuring out crazy ways to do it
i i was going to do a show i ended up
not because of my album release but
um the university of illinois wanted me
to do their
fall big performance where they were
going to have me in their
seventy thousand person stadium
performing in the middle you know like a
rolling stones type vibe right
crazy university university of illinois
right the big one in urbana-champaign
which is like this big
you know it's like it's the big school
in illinois
they wanted me to do their fall show in
this huge stadium where they play their
big football games
but they were gonna have eight seats in
between each
person right so they were gonna have
this huge
huge thing filled up i'm not it's huge
stadium eight seats eight seats between
six
that's at least six oh my oh yeah yeah
so it would have been like
i think it would have been like ten like
not ten thousand would have been less
than ten thousand i'm not good at math
anymore but yeah something like six to
eight thousand people in this
giant stadium and and i was like this
will be really weird but it's not like
i'm gonna ever have an experience with
this again
so i was hyped to do it but but then
yeah i'll release it into it
but people are finding creative ways to
do shows for sure
they are i've heard of a couple of
artists again
bringing up billy eilish i think she did
one that was virtual i don't know how
that went
other than virginia i was recording into
like a
uh uh hair brush
not recording it really just i was just
literally on
ig live just like playing my music on a
speaker and like yelling into a
hairbrush i'm sure that did it go well
really she probably had a classier one
oh my fans loved it it was like it was
like a cute little bonnie experience
i'm sure that there's classier ways of
doing it and fancier ways of doing it
but
mine was great i think billy eilish's
was a bit fancy i heard that
there's a lot of money invested into
that yeah it was a huge it was
like a show they wanted me to do
something like that and i said no i
think my fans like it just as much
i'm in my bedroom so roll with that uh
probably also you want to go to the show
yeah right next to people you want to be
like crunched up against people
mm-hmm i miss that feeling yeah yeah
miss crowd surfing that's vibe you miss
crowdsurfing
yes i would but i do many things that
are really stupid you should do it you
should come to a show and do it with me
i love making people i would always have
my friends that like i'm going to take
you up on that but if i
i've got fake joints if i if i get hurt
well i've i i've never been dropped
before
right but believe it or not i've never
been dropped i weighed 215 pounds i've
never been dropped
by the fans before but i did break my
hand in new zealand because
somebody like was head banging and like
hit their head
head against my hand really hard i'm
sure we both got hurt but i broke my
like hand pretty bad um
but you'll be fine dude i've i every
time i have a friend
um whether like who moved off to some
city come to a show i'll always like
really make him uncomfortable peer
pressure him into doing it like yo
everybody here's my boy chad
he's gonna jump on you right now and
you know it's it's that sounds great so
so come to the show we'll make it happen
where do you live right now
i'm in toronto i'm still in canada i was
gonna move
i was gonna go to texas but covet
happened and i'm
i'm here well toronto and texas are two
of my main
places i tour so i'll be in either one
okay
that sounds very good uh where can
people find you online
just look up young gravy you'll probably
spell it wrong but it'll still come up
it's spelled y-u-n-g gravy
uh any social media or whatever you use
it'll probably
probably be able to find it uh
it's the same on everything on gravy and
check out the song
the new song oops oops very catchy it's
big
it's dropping yeah they're gonna love it
or you're gonna hate it 10 minutes yeah
it's definitely a love or hate one yep
i love it and
um what do i use the most uh uh
instagram tic tac twitter youtube
find me there sounds good thank you very
much for coming on
thank you this has been fun about this
has been fun
thank you well it's a pleasure i'll go
drop this video
come watch it
you